did you ever get like because like when
i
you know started to get a little more
you know attention online and you know
because i never told any of my friends
like i didn't tell any of my friends in
college or high school or anything oh
yeah i didn't even tell any of my like
only my close friends yeah i didn't even
tell my close friends like there was
just like a thing to myself and then you
had a montana moment yeah
i didn't have the best of both worlds
so like you know so i i noticed it when
i randomly got like
one day i went on to like facebook
messenger and i got like 10 messages
from like high school friends i haven't
spoken to since i graduated they were
like yeah i found you on youtube when
did you start that we should hang out or
something and i was just like
no
i don't think so like you didn't have
that at all
maybe like a few that were like oh let's
meet up or did you get someone recently
on league who's like messaging oh
there's someone i played league of
legends with he was cool about it though
there was someone i played league of
legends with back in high school right
like i never even met them in person oh
okay but okay like it was like an online
friend yeah right but i hadn't spoken to
them in years yeah you got them from the
friends list you just left them on the
friends yesterday yeah yeah they're like
last online five years ago or whatever
actually my first night in japan they
had like messaged me yeah all right they
were like hey can i ask you like a
really bizarre question and i'm like
what's up and he's like
funny thing is he didn't even
find out from like my youtube he found
out from like a youtuber clip yeah right
so he was like
a
tuber now
and i was like
why
and he's like oh i found like a
i found a clip because my league name uh
is is emery um yeah and so he he sort of
was like well marichu emery that kind of
sounds similar yeah both of their names
are emily right is this you and i was
like miss you
and i was like yeah
and he's like oh okay i just want to
confirm that's super cool like good job
yeah
he was super cool about it yeah that's
good though it was really nice and i was
like oh yeah like hope and then we
caught up and i was like how have you
been doing
yeah
no yeah it's really weird for me because
like when when i when i did youtube as
my job i didn't really get so many
messages from people in my past just
randomly messaging me it was when
i moved to japan
and because it wasn't even about youtube
i would just get random messages to be
like oh i heard you like living in japan
now i've always wanted to visit
but they would find out because i
because of trash taste right but they
wouldn't be interested in like my work
or anything that'd be like so they're
like finally a tour guide yeah yeah
so it's a free tour right now yes i like
it so if i come over here
you can show me around right first time
literally my entire
yeah now you know my pain
i think it's been like a blessing and a
curse that the country's been closed
yeah
you're just going to get like a massive
rush of people to be like saw him in
japan
show me around how they're like join the
queue
here take your number yeah joe's got
like an online booking form for this
time yeah honestly you just go to this
website you fill it in table
reservations rsvp right here it's got
like the tour guide the ready i got the
flag
so how was the process
coming here like how was the getting the
visa and all that we asked dad is the
same thing too it wasn't that terrible i
think you got you guys are like the
guinea pigs
yeah yeah
yeah that would definitely yeah
the only thing that like really made the
process difficult was you know covet
stuff yeah obviously obviously um
my my embassy experience was a little
more stressful than dides's i'd say
so he might he probably explained it but
for him the way he got his visa was
didn't even make an appointment went to
boston rolled up hey uh i've got this
from this
and they're like all right come back in
a week he's like cool bye yeah
my closest embassy was l.a okay i'm
betting they were a lot busier oh yeah
so i called to be like can i make an
appointment and the lady was like okay
here's what you gotta do so tonight at
around 11 59 p.m there's gonna a few
slots are going to open up but people
want those slots you gotta like hunger
games that [ __ ] oh my god i was like
well really okay
um
and ended up getting one slot
such a police set to like set an alarm
to be like all right i'm going to phone
now refreshing now i've painted
refreshing it oh you're watching oh my
god um i got it and then
two days later got an email that was
like due to the high number of visa
applications we are no longer taking
in-person appointments uh-huh so you
gotta mail your stuff in by the way you
need to sign this waiver saying that if
we lose your [ __ ] it's not our fault and
i was like
i was so stressed
um it worked out though yeah i got my
visa yeah and then um
i think getting to the the whole i think
the most difficult like physically
mentally difficult part for me was when
i finally landed and i had to go through
this three-hour queue yeah yeah
yeah
and show my passport like 17 times yeah
different people yeah yeah i had to show
my doc and like the worst part was if
i'm wearing a mask you can't tell that
i'm
a different type of asian yeah yeah yeah
so at everything can you tell with the
mask off that you're like korean
no i don't think even even though i was
gonna say can you distinguish between
japanese and korean like just by looking
um
yeah my i want to i went to see an ear
doctor a few days ago and he knew
immediately i was korean it was
really cool yeah he looks at the shape
of urine you're like you're korean
i didn't even look at your face it's
like that's a korean right there i mean
it's like can you tell the difference
between a british person and a french
person if they don't open that maybe
that's because i'm white i feel like
sometimes i can yeah yeah it's it's like
every time but like
you can kind of tell subtle
or i can tell like when a white person
doesn't speak english
i can't tell that yeah i can't tell them
i can't tell them look it's coming on
look they're going to they go
they haven't watched like all eight
seasons of 24. you know what i mean i
can just like tell i've gotten pretty
good at like kind of distinguishing
between chinese and japanese but
sometimes korean and japanese it's like
you really don't know until they open
their mouth yeah for me it's like a lot
of the time there's a difference in like
makeup or style
[Music]
which is like the big difference
it's like if
makeup fashion style that's like no i'm
like i'm like is this asian girl dressed
like everyone around her probably
japanese yeah yeah skirt length is a big
towel yeah yeah yeah yeah i think that's
the biggest tell to figure out that's
something like yeah
it's like can i see your knees
i have to save
i have never felt more like
skanky
than
that's why i said that okay i i'm not
looking at people's skirts
and i'm like it's short skirt weather
baby let's go i'm wearing a shirt i'm
wearing like a a skirt let's go i walk
out everyone's covered head to toe yeah
japanese women normally wear skirts like
literally down to like here yeah like it
is like ankle covered like we're in the
1700s
and i'm like oh my god i hope i don't
look like
tacky and classless yeah but also it's
hot why
well i don't understand how like
japanese businessmen no matter how hot
it is we'll wear a suit fully but that's
why with a vest underneath that's why so
many people here die of heat strokes
yeah because they're literally just like
no i must not show any skin whatsoever i
will die for my course but then on the
opposite side of things sometimes it
gets like dead in the winter and the
girls are still wearing like even
shorter skirts
like how does that make sense right
they're still wearing the skirts and
everyone is just like i'm like dude you
have like a bath towel on how are you
like people either assume right away i'm
a foreigner or they think i'm just like
a very bold
yeah japanese yeah they're making a
statement
is that a careful whoa
have you had a lot of awkward encounters
or people think you speak japanese
because you oh my god that was my entire
three-hour airport experience i would go
to the next document
and i'm like what kind of night here are
my documents and they're like oh [ __ ] oh
okay uh do this and i'm like okay cool
next night
what kind of knife hear myself did you
see did you see like because this
happened to me a few a few times and
every time they get it wrong that i see
like the disappointment in their eyes it
makes me feel so bad i
yeah you know i've been learning you've
been doing really well really yeah i
mean you like go out there like i was
like i'll just say this and then you
immediately you're like i'm gonna say it
i'm gonna do it i'm still ordering and i
was like wow okay that's the best way to
learn it man yeah
because i mean normally like you know
it's understandably it's quite
intimidating having to say a bunch of
things that you don't really fully
understand why you're saying them but
you'd hope to get a certain amount
because then the moment they say
something off script you're just yeah
yeah yeah yeah what do i say this wasn't
part of my training
oh my god
that's good though yeah that's good i
noticed every time i hang out with
connor like i i think we have like
different gaps in our knowledge of
japanese so sometimes someone will say
something and i'm just like i kind of
miss that and kind of like immediately
get that and sometimes sometimes someone
will say something connor's just like uh
donato answered i know what to answer
and it's just between me and connor i
think we have like respect
because he'll finish my standards for me
but like yeah how have you started
taking lessons yeah so i i've done one
lesson so far i do them every week yeah
uh except the past two weeks i couldn't
because my teacher
uh she was busy and then it was golden
week yeah so my next lesson isn't until
a few days but i know how to like
introduce myself yeah i just i was like
just just take my teacher just get her
yeah
very very enthusiastic she's not like
the youtuber teacher because she's
basically she's literally teaching all
the youtubers english sydney emily dylan
building an empire